voici une salle de classe pour grand
jardinier au programme une quinzaine de
formation étalée sur une année
présentées par des spécialistes de la
nature insectes plantes sauvages oiseaux
et entretien de son jardin tout est fait
pour vous apprendre à devenir un
véritable éco jardinier et maîtriser le
cycle de vie d'une plante est donc se
passer de produits chimiques
le 5 juillet dernier le parc naturel de
chevreuse invité jean marc prince a
présenté le dernier atelier de ce cycle
de formation sur la taille des arbres
fruitiers
le centre d'initiation la thur des eaux
baignères a accueilli ses grands
jardiniers en herbe pour discuter de la
taille en vert pommiers poiriers
noisetier ou encore cerisier 14
participants ont pu échanger pendant une
après-midi à propos des arbres fruitiers
de leur jardin convivialité
apprentissage ce sont des formations à
liancourt et travaux pratiques pour
devenir de vrais pros du jardinage
j'ai pas un très très grand terrain donc
j'ai pas encore de vergers donc j'ai
débuté des greffes depuis deux saisons
pour démarrer des arbres et l'objectif
est d'avoir un terrain un peu plus grand
dans quelques années pour justement
avoir un verger
donc il ya un pommier poirier de
cerisiers et puis quelqu'un abricotiers
j'ai jamais vu un abricot depuis dix ans
que je suis et puis pas mal de pruniers
ces ateliers pratiques sont des moments
de partage d'astuces et de méthode entre
particuliers trois habitués ou novices
chacun pourra appliquer les méthodes de
retour dans son jardin
les participants sont heureux d'en
apprendre un maximum et n'attendent
qu'une chose d'autres formations
havas au dessus de l'oeil plaque comme
ça on est sur du coup au dessus de
l'oeil plat pour celle qu'on la bonne et
simple raison si vous faites ça va vous
d'écrabouiller votre élève jardiniers et
spécialistes de la nature on vous attend
donc nombreux pour le prochain cycle de
formation l'année prochaine
[Musique]